Today,
we're going to learn about the three types of contractual damage remedies
through the case of Sullivan versus O'Connor,
which was decided by the Supreme Judicial Court of Massachusetts in 1973 Alice
Sullivan was a professional entertainer and she had a problem.
Her nose was excessively long and prominent.
She found a plastic surgeon,
Dr. James O'Connor,
who promised to quote,
enhance her beauty and improve her appearance.
Legend has it.
He promised her and knows just like the movie star Hetty Lamar Sullivan was
supposed to undergo two surgeries in order to achieve this effect for a fee of
$622.
Instead,
however,
solve and underwent three surgeries,
uh,
that went badly and ended up with an uglier knows than the one she had started
with.
It was bulbous,
flattened and broadened in the middle and the tip had lost symmetry.
Sullivan sued Dr. O'Connor for both breach of contract and for medical
malpractice.
The jury ruled for the doctor on the medical malpractice claim.
That is it found that he had exercise the care and judgment that could be
expected from a professional like him,
but awarded the plaintiff $13,500 of damages for breach of contract.
The opinion we've read is the decision of the highest court of the state of
Massachusetts on appeal.
The justices cannot evaluate questions of fact,
but instead are looking at whether the judge instructed the jury correctly on
how to calculate damages.
Uh,
the judge had instructed them that Solvan could re could recover out of pocket
expenses,
directed direct damages from the disfigurement of her nose and pain and
suffering from the third operation,
the extra one that she was not supposed to undergo the defendant,
a Dr. O'Connor took exception to the judge's instructions saying they were
flawed,
that that Solvan should at most be able to recover just her out of pocket
expenses.
The court must decide whether a,
that argument is correct,
if it decides in favor of the defendant,
Solvan can receive at most $622 in direct costs and not anything else that the
jury awarded her.
The central issue then is Kana.
Patient received damages based on anything other than the direct expenses,
the fees she paid in particular,
uh,
for pain and suffering and for the failure to achieve the promised result.
Originally Sullivan also took exception to the instructions.
The judge had suggested that she could receive damages based on the difference
between the nose,
uh,
with which he began and the nose she ended up with.
But she thought she should be able to receive the difference between Hedley
Lamarr,
his nose,
the nose she was promised,
and the no she ended up with.
However,
by the time this opinion was written,
she had waved this objection.
And so justice Kaplan had no ability to change the award in her favor.
She might have been able to get a larger award if she had preserved her
objection on appeal.
So Justice Kaplan first asks whether the enforcement of the physicians,
uh,
promise is against public policy.
Courts had been skeptical for a couple reason about enforcing such promises.
First,
doctors can sell them in good faith,
promise specific results,
the court said.
And so they typically do not make such promises of courts do not want to turn
every enthusiastic remark about a procedure into a guarantee that's,
uh,
that will lead to litigation.
Second,
courts have been suspicious that Pa,
uh,
patients bring contract claims are merely line to get around the statute of
limitations for medical malpractice claims,
which are more appropriate in such a matters.
Uh,
but Justice Kaplan also recognizes that some doctors may on occasion a guarantee
results and he thinks that the jury could find that to be the case for Doctor
uh,
O'Connor.
He therefore concludes that contractual remedies are not forbidden.
Uh,
uh,
for all medical cases,
this position makes sense because at least some of the time physicians may be
the least cost.
Avoiders other providers of goods and services sometimes give guarantees that
their products will work consistently,
even if they do occasionally fail.
And we think that it's a good policy since the manufacturers,
uh,
or service providers are often in the best position to control,
the risks of failure.
So for some medical operations.
This may also be the case with regard to physicians.
In this case,
Justice Kaplan considered different purposes of contract remedies in order to
determine what damages solving is entitled to receive.
Section three 44 of the restatement summarizes the three main interest that
contract damages protect judicial remedies under the rules stated in the
restatement serve to protect one or more of the following interests,
uh,
of a promise.
See a his expectation interest,
which is his or her interest in having the benefit of the bargain by being put
in as good a position as he or she would have been in had the contract been
performed be the reliance interest,
which is his or her interest in being reimbursed for the loss caused by relying
on the contract.
And you do this by being put in as good a position as he or she would have been
in had the contract not been made.
And finally,
there's something called the restitution and trust,
which is a plaintiff's interest in having restored to him any benefit that he
converted on the defendant.
Let's look at each of these damage interests.
In turn.
First,
the expectation interest is the one that is most commonly awarded as damages in
contract law.
When a court awards a plaintiff,
a expectation damages,
it tries to put the plaintiff in as good a position as she would have been in
had the defendant perform the contract.
As promised to assess expectation damages,
we have to compare the position of the plaintiff that the plaintiff would have
been in if the defendant had perfectly performed,
uh,
his promise.
With the position we find the plaintiff.
And now the idea is that when one party breaches the contract,
he has no right to worse in the other party's relative to position to what it
would have been if the contract had been performed in law and economics.
This principle is connected to the idea of the efficient breach.
A party should breach a contract only when he receives benefits from doing so
that are enough to compensate the other party for her losses from the breach.
We can consider what expectation damages would look like in this case.
In the world promised by the contract.
Solvan would have paid $622 experienced pain and suffering from to operations
and wound up with a nose like Hedy Lamarr's.
Instead,
she paid the fee experienced pain and suffering from three operations and wound
up with the defiguration knows the difference between these two positions which
he would recover under the expectation damage measure is the pain and suffering
from the third operation and the difference between a beautiful nose and it
disfigured.
One.
Justice Kaplan describes the general unenthusiastic or skepticism of courts
about applying expectation damages in medical cases.
The judges think that doctors promises of cures are just statements of opinions
with some optimistic coloring and that enforcing the expectation interest could
leave doctors to practice defensive medicine.
It's also very difficult to calculate the value of a purely hypothetical end
result,
but Kaplan also cites the famous case of Hawkins vs Mcgee from New Hampshire in
1929 in which a man did recover expectation damages from a physician.
The doctor had promised to give him a good or perfect tanned and so his damages
were based on the difference in value between such a hand and the mangled and
Harry one that he ended up in.
So just as Kaplan cannot rule out the expectation,
uh,
interest as a possible damage measure when a warring reliance damages.
In contrast,
the goal is to put the plaintiff back in the position she occupied just before
the parties entered into upon the agreement.
So to assess reliance damages,
we have to compare the plaintiff's position just before entering the contract
with the position we find her in.
Now in this case,
Ms. Sullivan would never have paid $622.
She would never have experienced pain and suffering from any of the operations
and she would still have our old nose.
She would be entitled to the value of all of three of these in damages under our
reliance measure of damages.
Just as Kaplan points out that New York courts have begun to apply this type of
damages in patient physician contract cases and he seems to favor this because
of the reasons he gave for being skeptical about large expectation awards and
medical cases.
He also cites contemporary research by fuller in Purdue who argued that
expectation damages make the most sense in commercial context,
but that reliance damages should be the default form of damages in other
context.
While that view has never fully caught on justice Kaplan found it persuasive,
it's worth noticing that in some situations the difference between expectation
and reliance damages vanishes.
Suppose for example that there had been a second doctor who would have made a
similar promise and would have succeeded in giving Sullivan a heady Lamarr like
nose.
Then the plaintiff could argue that in reliance on doctor Connors promise,
she turned down the alternative offer from the other physician.
Her position,
if you had not entered into the contract with Dr. O'Connor is that she would
have entered into a successful contract with the other doctor.
So the alternative situation that forms the basis for calculating damages looks
the same for both reliance and expectation.
We compare Sullivan is disfigured,
knows to the perfect nose.
That is the reliance damage damages end up incorporating Selvans opportunity
costs in selecting Dr. O'Connor over the competing physician,
the restitution interest.
The third measure of damages is discussed less frequently and is concerned with
ensuring that the party that has breached a contract doesn't get to keep the
benefits he or she received from the uh,
contract in this case.
That would mean that doctor Connor would have to pay back the $622 fee he
received from Sullivan.
While this is the sort of damages that Dr. O'Connor argues for Justice Kaplan
never seriously contemplates this as an option as it would be plainly to meager
while expectation and reliance focus on the plaintiffs positions.
Uh,
restitution focuses on the defendant's positions.
The more standard type of restitution attempts to put the defendant in the
position he or she would have been in a had the contract not been bade.
It does compare as the position we find the defendant in with the position the
doctor was in just before making the contract.
We find the doctor and the position of having received fees and having expanded
effort in three operations to put the doctor and the ex ante position,
we would need to force the doctor disgorge the fees paid less,
some discount for the physicians effort,
but restitution often for simplicity might just force the disgorgement of the
fees paid.
By the way,
if uh,
you should be able to create a two by two chart,
uh,
with expectation reliance and restitution in three of the four boxes and realize
that there is a fourth measure of damages which that would strive to put the
doctor in the ex post position that is in the position as if the contract had
been fully performed.
I discussed just that possibility in my two by two lecture and the law students
toolkit course.
This table provides a summary of the conclusions with uh,
come to over the past few slides along with the judge's instruction to the jury.
As you can see,
his instructions don't quite match either reliance damages or expectation
damages.
Let's go through a few of the categories.
First of all,
with regard to the doctor's fees,
the doctor's fees are available as damages under the reliance measure since
Sullivan wouldn't have paid them if not for the existence of the contract.
If not for her reliance on the contract,
she cannot recover them.
However,
under the expectation measure because she would have paid them if the operation
had been successful here the trial judge's instructions match the reliance
measure now with regard to out of pocket fees and the pain and suffering they
both work in the same way.
Under the reliance measure,
the plaintiff can recover for all three operations since none of the operations
would have happened without contract existing without her reliance on the
contract.
However,
under the expectation measure,
the plaintiff can only recover damages for the third operation because she would
have paid the fees and experienced the pain and suffering of the first two
operations even if the operations had been successful.
Note,
however,
that the trial judge's instructions match the reliance measure for out of pocket
fees,
but the less gender generous expectancy measure for pain and suffering.
This may reflect the judges greater comfort in breach of contract cases with
compensation for monetary costs than with compensation for pain and suffering.
The damage categories relating to lost earnings and to the value of solar ovens
knows itself also form a similar pair.
They worked the same way when protecting the reliance interest.
We want to put Solvan back in the position she was in before the contract was
formed and so we calculate the difference between her situation then and her
situation.
Now when protecting the expectation interest,
we want to put Solvan into the hypothetical position.
She would have been in had Dr. O'Connor accomplished as promised a operation and
so we calculate the difference between the hypothetical situation of her having
a better knows and solvents actual situation.
We don't have any evidence of the trial court's view on lost earnings though it
looks like reliance damages because the court did not contemplate how much
Solvan might have earned if she looked like Hetty Lamar.
But we know that the judge instructed the jury to calculate reliance damages for
the value of her nose.
The final result in the case reflects the general principle that common law
judges apply and making decisions.
The only answer the questions that they absolutely must hear.
Justice Kaplan is only deciding whether Sullivan can receive damages for pain
and suffering for the third operation and damages for the worse and conditioned
of her nose.
It turns out that whether Justice Kaplan chooses expectancy damages or reliance
damages,
she'd be entitled to uh,
these,
uh,
two forms of damages either way,
so it's not necessary for him to pick expectation or reliance damages.
First,
let's think about the pain and suffering damages for the third operation.
In the expectation damages view,
Ms. Sullivan is entitled to these because she was only supposed to undergo two
operations in the reliance damages view,
Solvan would be entitled of these along with pain and suffering for the first
two operations because we're trying to put her back in the,
she was in before she made an agreement with Dr. O'Connor.
Now let's think about the damages from the worst and conditioned of her nose.
It's clear that Solvan is entitled to these on the reliance damages view because
these damages simply reflect the harm O'Connor did to her,
which we're trying to make right in the expectancy view.
On the other hand,
she'd be entitled to the difference between the Hetty Lamar perfect nose and the
disfigured one she wound up with,
but these damages would definitely be larger and so she's at least entitled to
the amount of the jury warded her under the instruction the judge gave.
So again,
Justice Kaplan doesn't even have to come to a conclusion about what types of
damages are appropriate in this case because the plaintiff wins either way.
He doesn't declare a general rule.
Had Alice Silva not waived her rebuttal claims to the other types of damages,
he might have had to come to a decision about whether she could receive
expectation damages for the disfigurement of her nose.
It's true that she received her out of pocket expenses for all three operations,
which would only be valid,
valid under a reliance measure.
But that issue was not before the Supreme Judicial Court in this case because
neither of the parties challenged it.
So let's take a little quiz.
Imagine that Michael has yellow teeth and Dr. Smith promises to make them white,
but instead they end up brown.
Michael Sues for breach of contract.
Which of the following would be calculated for expectation damages?
The answer is the second is the second answer here.
It's the difference in the value between the white and the brown teeth.
It's the difference between what the position he ends up with is with Brown
teeth in the position he was promised was the white teeth,
which is what is get granted by expectation damages.
Okay.
And now here's a related question.
It's the same hypothetical,
but the question is which of the following would be calculated for reliance
damages?
The correct answer is number three,
the difference in value between yellow and brown teeth.
Uh,
for reliance damages,
we're trying to put the party,
the non breaching party back in the position as if the contract had not been
formed.
The position with the,
that Michael was in before the contract was having yellow teeth.
Uh,
the position he ended up with was brown teeth and so we have to come up with a
monetary value for the difference between having yellow and brown teeth from
reading Sullivan and O'connor.
We've learned about three different damage measures that may help protect
people's contractual interests.
Expectation damages,
try to put the non breaching party in the same position she would have been in
had the contract been carried out.
These are most common in a commercial contract cases.
Reliance damages in contrast,
try to put the non breaching party in the same position she would have been in
had the contract never been entered and restitution damages try to pull back
from the breaching party any benefit that he or she received from the contract.
The general rule is that plaintiffs can choose which of the three damaged
measures they want to pursue in contractual breach cases.
Now,
at least as an initial starting point,
defendants can have an ability to,
uh,
suggest that under some circumstances there that expectations would,
for example,
be over compensatory.
But as a starting matter,
the plaintiffs have the right to choose among these three and often choose
expectation as the most beneficial.
In this case,
Alice Sullivan waived some of the additional damages she might have received
under the expectation measure.
Had she pursued a different litigation strategy,
she might have one more,
or Justice Kaplan might've explicitly ruled against awarding expectation damages
in medical cases.